from new promotion photos of the seventh
season have recently been released and
basically every single one of them is
either confirming or going favor to at
least one main event that we are about
to see in the upcoming season let's
start with a bunch of photos of a huge
meeting that will take place in
Winterfell which is once again
confirming that in the very first
episode of the upcoming season the king
in the north along with northern Lords
and the other important people will have
a meeting regarding fate of the northern
houses that betrayed them by supporting
the Bolton's if you are wondering how am
I so sure that this meeting will return
fate of treasonous northern houses well
in this shot we can once again see an
actress that will portray daughter of
regard Karstark and is most certainly an
heir of house Karstarks since as I
already said in previous videos her
father and two brothers died a long time
ago while her only remaining brother
Herald will either be executed or sent
to the wall for his betrayal as we can
see this meeting will attend obviously
King in the north himself well we can
also notice that he's sharing a table
with lady of Winterfell Sansa Stark just
like in the season six finale but now
they're accompanied with Davos Seaworth
who is at this point most likely hand of
the king we can also see Lord Robert
Glover Lord Royce lady Mormont tormund
Brienne of Tarth
Podrick Littlefinger as well as Ellis
car Sarkar self there are few more shots
of this meeting providing a closer look
at roof last lady moment who is most
likely proposing to other Lords enter
the King in the north himself that
reason his houses should be punished we
also get to see a shot of Turman giving
a speech to northern Lords as well as to
the lords from the wail and to the
Knights of the Vale
as you can see Lord Royce in the
background while it's not certain
whether or not he is supporting lady
Mormont's proposal in conclusion this
meeting that includes king in the north
all Lords as well as Elise Karstark
herself will the turn fate of her house
which will most likely result with Jon
Snow's refusal to hold ellis responsible
for her brother's betrayal while there
are a few photos similar to already
published ones just taken from different
angle there are a lot of new photos that
are providing us first look at certain
characters such as this one of bearing
Gandhari and traveling and leading the
Brotherhood without banners to the north
this photo is once again confirming that
beric Dondarrion
the Brotherhood without banners to the
north which is not surprising at all
since Burke himself already revealed his
intentions of traveling north to fight
against the great evil in a conversation
with the hound a conversation in which
Barrack recruited senator Colgan into
their newest mission however while their
mission of traveling north to fight
against the great evil is not surprising
this same shot is once again supporting
and this point already confirmed event
of the upcoming season witches Jon
Snow's mission beyond the wall that will
contain small group of people including
sender Clegane Thoris of mere and beric
Dondarrion himself if you would like to
hear more details about this confirmed
event of the seventh season that will
result with the deaths of a few main
characters and possibly with the death
of one the nurses dragon feel free to
check out my video by the name Jon
Snow's mission explained we also get to
see that was Ebert and Jon Snow just
about to leave Winterfell for
Dragonstone place on which John in the
near soul meet for the very first time
even though Jon Snow's main intention
will not be to meet the nearest but
rather to collect as much dragon glass
as he can in case sit on no dragon glass
is the only substance beside Valyrian
steel capable of killing the White
Walkers and large amounts of it can be
found on Dragonstone island we also get
to see a lot of shots of the nurses
arrival at Dragonstone as well as a
bunch of shots of similarly in Gilly in
old town at the Citadel besides Sam
either reading or looking for the books
to read there's also one pretty
interesting shot of him with the bloody
outfit at the Citadel which is most
likely part of his training to become
maester those several shots of Samuel
being surrounded the books is a strong
clue that Sam will either find out an
important information that will
eventually turn the Great War in their
favor or we'll find out a cure for Juris
disease other than that we also get to
see Brent Starks still beyond the wall
looking up presumably at the wall then
we have Thurmond and Podrick in
Winterfell while Jamie Lannister is in
the red keep probably accompanied with
Cersei and is working on a new strategic
plan that would extend Circe's reign a
bit longer whether or not they will
succeed